نقاط سودت كشفت مع الهبه التضامنيه لنجده
المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا رغم
النقاط المضيئه التي حملتها استغلال في
ابشع صوره ومحاوله خداع من يرغبون في
التبرع لضحايا الكارثه الطبيعيه التي قلبت
حياه العشرات لماساه حقيقيه فالكثير من
المحتالين عبر من منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
يزعمون انهم يجمعون تلك الاموال للناجين
الذين تركوا بدون ماوى او تدفئه او ماء
بعد الكارثه التي حلت بهم ولكن بدلا من
مساعده المحتاجين يقوم المحتلون بتحقيق
مكاسب ماديه من خلال تحويل التبرعات بعيدا
عن المؤسسات الخيريه الحقيقيه الى
حساباتهم على تطبيق باي بال ومحافظ
العملات المشفره التي يملكونها فعلى موقع
تويتر انشا محتلون حسابات وهميه تحمل صورا
مؤثره ون روابط لحسابات على بايبال لجمع
التبرعات ومن اهم الطرق والادوات التي
يستخدمها المحتلون ايضا البث المباشر على
منصات التواصل فتطبيق تيك توك تحصل على
نسبه 70% من عوائد الهدايا الرقميه في
حينفت الشركه صحه الخبر كما ان حساب
التركي ريليفا الذي لديه واحد وثلاثون
متابعا فقط وانضم الى تويتر من خلال
الترويج للتبرعات عبر باي بال تلقى حتى
الان تبرعات بقيمه 900 دولار امريكي سرقه
اموال المعاناه تاتي فيما الالاف يبيتون
في العراء وستقصاوه البرد وحلمهم الوحيد
الحصول على خيمه ما ودنا لمن ظالم عن
السكر